c'est à bord de son tracteur que fait
les bourreaux darcis en séchant
plusieurs fois par jour
car la ville maraîchers ne donne aucun
répit surtout avec les aléas de dame
nature
changement climatique mais maintenant on
est pris avec des sabots jobin chaque
année les changements climatiques lui
apporte de nouveaux défis travers des
japonais doivent 4 500 de nouveaux
insectes de nouvelles maladies un
réservoir d'eau souvent à sec des écarts
de température qui fort son équipe a
travaillé dans des conditions souvent
pénibles sans compter les fruits et
légumes qui ne pousse plus ou encore
trop rapidement on se ramasse avec
destruction près peu trop tôt quand même
une problématique parce que le marché
primaire de la citrouille et pour les
décorations d'halloween donc cette année
on arrête faire j'avais proposé
le mot d'ordre donc s'adapter avec son
alto gourmand telle auto cueillette il
peut vendre des fruits et des légumes
qui en raison des grandes chaleurs ne
sont plus à la hauteur de l'esthétisme
héros qui pourraient être vendus en
épicerie
puis le maraîcher a dernièrement investi
à grands frais dans un immense système
de ventilation il espère ainsi que sa
production reste fraîche et qu'il
trouvera des acheteurs bientôt pour
éviter du gaspillage alimentaire tout
cela apporte une série de
questionnements savoir ce qu'on continue
ou on arrête on est tout le temps aussi
à se demander est ce que c'est la fin
est ce qu'on peut avoir une certaine
stabilité dans cette culture
et comme défi n'attend pas l'autre avec
la pandémie fils ait pas eu de la
difficulté à faire venir ces
travailleurs étrangers ces travailleurs
selon lui assure la sécurité alimentaire
au pays s'il n'était pas là il y aurait
simplement au cas où les étalages prévu
dans les supermarchés c'est simple la
pandémie a démontré l'importance de la
sécurité alimentaire au canada et
pourtant malgré les événements liés aux
changements climatiques des dernières
années les partis en campagne ne semble
pas en faire une priorité on parle pas
beaucoup d'environnements relier
l'agriculture mars auprès d'acteurs
allez on n'en parle pas de façon
générale pascal thériault croit que des
investissements en recherche sont
essentiels pour l'agriculture et la
sécurité alimentaire spécialement en ces
temps incertains c'est important
d'investir chez nous nos entreprises
agricoles plus conventionnel mais il
faut aussi donner une chance au petit
entrepreneur ou à toute cette
commercialisation père circuits courts
de vente directe de pouvoir se déployer
de pouvoir se développer parce que
constitue un
filet de sécurité important
il était déçu de constater que les chefs
en campagne ne voit pas l'urgence d'agir
je tends peut résulter de voir la
position des gouvernements qui
n'êtes pas des points sur les i qu'à
propos des actions concrètes on voit les
météos qui sont chambres allant qui vont
d'un extrême à l'autre puis ça apporte
toutes sortes de problématiques sur les
producteurs agricoles malgré
l'inquiétude philippe est un grand
passionné s'accroche au petit côté
positif des variations de température
les chaleurs intenses des dernières
années lui permettent maintenant de
faire pousser de l'ocrha dont le marais
un légume qui avant n'aimait pas les
terres québécoises de vraiment bon ici
elisa cr radio-canada rougement